un hlm du 12e arrondissement au fond
d'une cour une petite musique pour le
moins inhabituel
[Musique]
nous sommes chez tes à noa noa par
houari théa pour les intimes chez lui on
se croirait presque à tahiti pourtant ce
musicien de 28 ans a débarqué à paris
dans une grenouillère à l'âge de deux
mois sont ils il ne l'a vraiment connu
qu'une seule fois à 16 ans il est parti
à la rencontre de sa mère elle lui a
offert son premier au cou l'ailé depuis
il en joue comme personne
c'est
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
lors d
[Musique]
ati ti à l'époque c'était c'était donc
tout simplement une espèce de bois qui
faisait office de manche avec une autre
co pour tout vêtement une note faucons
pour tous quitté la caisse de résonance
est ce qui n'a pas changé c'est le fils
de pêche
s'est dit fil des pages dans cette forme
du coup d'essai voilà tout simplement du
fil de pêche
aujourd'hui comme tous les samedis t as
pas répéter un groupe de danse n'étaye
kit amato qui prépare un spectacle
folklorique pour la foire de paris est
évidemment ils ont fait appel à lui dès
qu'il s'agit de musique tahitienne téa
est la référence et même si cela peut
paraître cliché pour les 7000 polynésien
de métropole loin de leurs collectivités
territoriales d'outre-mer tout passe
toujours par la danse et le chant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on va
on est baigné dans cette culture noire
la danse à la chambre les chambres dont
une certaine joie de vie
c'est les blés ça dans mon champ de mode
ans
non nous sourire donc voilà on danse
voilà
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on s'amuse certes mais on respecte les
codes
[Musique]
du côté gauche italie du côté du cac
elle est prise
célibataire ou accompagné tu es à l
europe traverse paris direction le
kremlin bicêtre une association
tahitienne a organisé dans un restaurant
une soirée pour venir en aide aux évacué
sanitaire de tahiti ce qu'on appelle les
evasan et qu'ils rsa année ce sont des
malades polynésiens qui sont donc en
polynésie qui
si pour certains donc n'arrive pas à
voir les soins nécessaires donc en
polynésie donc ils viennent en métropole
simplement pour se soigner c'est à dire
une personne qui vit à les 90 % de son
temps soit on parlait aux claquettes
tong tong ou short débardeur parce que
voilà un soleil magnifique et qui
arrivent en france où il fait le temps
qui fait surtout en ce moment
ouais c'est bien c'est bien d'avoir une
chaleur tout autre alors apporté chaleur
humaine tout simplement
et côté chaleur humaine rien ne résiste
à une bande de polynésiens même pas le
métro parisien
pour saler mais non ouais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quelques heures plus tard au restaurant
ou chantent encore la soirée pour
soutenir les malades polynésien a déjà
commencé et pour certains fraîchement
débarquée se réunir est un bon remède au
mal des îles
[Musique]
alors voilà je voulais je te présente
une une malade là c'est une maladie qui
est très réputé pour dire dans le monde
entier mais ce qui est vrai par son
travail c'est une excellente danseuse
ouais bon c'est peut-être vrai parce
qu'elle a une béquille l hévéa l'a fait
exprès de venir avec sa canne c'est pour
ça
que je suis ici pour des soins ça fait
depuis 2006 2007 je sue suivi pour un
français et
parmi ces malades qui ne peuvent être
soignés au pays comme mehiti il ya
également de nombreux d'irradier
victimes des essais nucléaires du mur
ruraux a
orchestré par la france de 65 96 ces
essais ont laissé de séquelles
irrémédiables sur la population mais
aussi sur la faune sous marine fille
toujours
pouvoir
barroso n'est en plus pas manger
tu vas manger suivra pour une maman
pour beaucoup de tahitiens la france est
loin d'avoir réparé ces erreurs même si
l assumer une part de ses
responsabilités mais aujourd'hui l'heure
n'est ni à la politique ni à la
polémique on pense plutôt à s'amuser
mais ici elle a d'ailleurs cédé à
l'appel dit amour et il a été plus fort
que sa maladie
est léger
par exemple on va dire une flèche le
[Musique]
souffle et le soleil on va faire ça
le ciel on montre le ciel
ça va
[Musique]
non